.
WHAT HORRIFYING DETAILS WE PRAY
FOR THE 99 THAT ARE STILL
MISSING.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE OUR
CONVERSATION THOUGH NOW ABOUT
CRITICAL RACE THEORY BECAUSE IT
IS THAT IMPORTANT AND IT LOOKS
LIKE IT COULD NOW BE
INFILTRATING THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY.
YOU ONLY HAVE TO LISTEN TO THE
WORDS OF THE JOINT CHIEFS
CHAIRMAN MARK MILLEY DESCRIBE,
QUOTE, WHITE RAGE AS THE REASON
FOR JANUARY 6TH PROTESTS.
>> I UNDERSTAND WHITE RAGE AND
I'M WHITE.
I WANT TO UNDERSTAND IT WHAT IS
IT THAT CAUSED THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE TO ASSAULT THIS BUILDING
AND TRY TO OVERTURN THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA, WHAT CAUSED
THAT, I WANT TO FIND THAT OUT.
>> Will: NOW THE MILITARY IS
STUDYING CRITICAL RACE THEORY
AND MILLIE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
DEFENDS IT SHOULD WOULD HE BE
EVEN SURPRISED?
SINCE BIDEN TOOK OFFICE THE CIA
AND EVEN NASA HAVE GONE WOKE.
DON'T WORRY MILLLY IS ALWAYS
UNDERSTANDING THE COUNTRY WE ARE
HERE TO DEFEND.
>> I HAVE READ MY IT TONGUE, I
HAVE READ KARL MARX AND LINEN.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ME COMMUNIST.
UNDERSTANDING OF THE COUNTRY TO
WHICH WE ARE HERE TO DEFEND.
>> Will: JOINING ME NOW IS
SENATOR TOM COTTON MEMBER OF THE
ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE.
SENATOR, ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE YOU
ON THE PROGRAM.
IS WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH THE
MILITARY DIFFERENT AND IF IT IS,
HOW SO, THEN WHAT WE ARE SEEING
HAPPEN WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
CLASSROOMS ACROSS THIS COUNTRY?
>> WELL, THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
WHAT WE SEE IN CLASSROOMS IN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IS VERY
ALARMING BECAUSE SCHOOLS ARE
TRYING TO INDOCTRINATE YOUNG
CHILDREN HATEFUL FUNDAMENTALLY
FLAWED IRREDEEMABLE COUNTRY
FRISMT WE ALLOW A GENERATION OF
OUR KIDS TO BE INDOCTRINATED
WITH THOSE VIEWS, THEN WHAT DOES
IT MATTER IF WE WIN A FEW
ELECTIONS IN THE YEAR AHEAD.
IN THE MILITARY IT IS AT BEST A
WASTE OF TIME TO HAVE STUDENTS
IN PROFESSIONAL MILITARY SCHOOLS
OR TROOPS GOING THROUGH TRAINING
SESSIONS BEING EXPOSED TO
CRITICAL RACE THEORY CONCEPTS.
BUT EVEN FURTHER IT HELPS
UNDERMINE UNIT COHESION AND
MORALE.
YOU KNOW, WHEN I WAS IN THE
ARMY, I CAN TELL YOU WE DIDN'T
LOOK AT EACH OTHER THROUGH THE
LENS OF RACE OR BACKGROUND OR
YOUR LAST NAME OR WHO YOUR
PARENTS WERE, WE LOOKED AT EACH
OTHER AS BATTLE BUDDIES,
COMRADES AT ARMS WHO SIGNED UP
TO FIGHT FOR OUR COUNTRY AND
WILLING TO I DO IN OUR COUNTRY
AND MEN RIGHT AND LEFT AND FRONT
AND REAR.
WHAT REALLY CAUSED KNEE DIG
DEEPER INTO THIS I HAVE A LOT OF
FRIENDS STILL IN THE SERVICE.
THEY STARTED REACHING TOUT ME A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO WITH SOME OF
THE TRAININGS THEY WERE FACING
AS A RESULT OF SECRETARY
AUSTIN'S SO-CALLED STAND DOWN
ORDER.
SINCE THEN CONGRESSMAN CRENSHAW
AND I HAVE BEEN GETTING A LOT OF
COMPLAINTS, HUNDREDS OF
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THESE TRAINING
SESSIONS.
THAT'S ONE REASON WHY I PRESSED
SECRETARY AUSTIN ON IT EARLIER
THIS WEEK AND I PRESSED THE
CHIEF OF NAVAL OPERATIONS
ADMIRAL GILDAY ABOUT IT AS WELL.
THE ARMY AND MILITARY AS A WHOLE
NEED TO FOCUS ON REAL WARS NOT
ON CULTURE WARS.
>> Will: YOU KNOW, SENATOR, I
LIKE HOW YOU DISTINGUISH
INDOCTRINATION FROM EDUCATION.
MILLIE SUGGESTS WE ARE ONLY
EDUCATING OURSELVES AND ARMY AS
WE LOOK INTO CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
HE SAYS AS YOU HEARD THERE I
HAVE READ MOVE THAT DOESN'T MAKE
ME A COMMUNIST.
I NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
IDEOLOGIES THAT ARE PRESENTED.
SOME OF THEM COULD BE OUR ENEMY.
THE PROBLEM IS IT SEEMS LIKE
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE
MILITARY IS LESS ABOUT EDUCATION
AND MORE ABOUT AS YOU POINTED
OUT INDOCTRINATION.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS AD FROM THE UNITED STATES
ARMY.
♪
>> IT BEGINS IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH A LITTLE GIRL RAISED BY TWO
MOMS.
I ALSO MARCHED FOR EQUALITY.
I LIKE TO THINK I HAVE BEEN
DEFENDING FREEDOM FROM AN EARLY
AGE AND AFTER MEETING WITH AN
ARMY RECRUITER, I FOUND IT.
A WAY TO PROVE MY INNER STRENGTH
AND MAYBE SHATTER SOME
STEREOTYPES ALONG THE WAY.
>> Will: THAT'S THE UNITED
STATES ARMY RECRUITING AD RIGHT
THERE, SENATOR.
SO WHEN I LOOK AT THAT I WORRY
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND I HOPE I'M
WRONG.
YOU SERVE, YOU ALSO SERVE IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
I HOPE I'M WRONG BUT WHAT I SEE
THERE FROM A DISTANCE IS WHAT
APPEARS TO BE NOT EDUCATION BUT
INDOCTRINATION.
>> YEAH, THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM THE FRONTLINE
TROOPERS, THE YOUNG PRIVATES,
SERGEANTS THROUGH THE BACKBONE
OF OUR MILITARY, OFFICERS WHO
OFTENTIMES ARE INVOLVED IN
HAVING TO CONDUCT THESE TRAINING
SESSIONS AND SOME CASES VERY
MUCH AGAINST THEIR WISHES.
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, THERE IS ALWAYS
A PLACE FOR INSTANCE, IN COLLEGE
CAMPUSES TO INCLUDE OUR SERVICE
ACADEMIES TO SAY READ KARL MARX
IN A CLASS ON THE HISTORY OF
WESTERN THOUGHT.
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO TRAINING
SESSIONS FOR OUR FRONTLINE
TROOPS, THEY NEED TO BE TAUGHT
TO RESPECT EVERYONE IRRESPECTIVE
OF THEIR RACE OR THEIR SEX OR
ETHNICITY OR RELIGIOUS CREED OR
POLITICAL VIEWS.
TREAT THEM WITH EQUAL DIGNITY
AND RESPECT, PERIOD.
THEY NEED TO GET BACK TO
TACTICAL EXCELLENCE AND
OPERATIONAL TRAINING SO WE CAN
PERFORM A HIGHEST LEVELS AND OUR
TROOPS CAN BE READY TO FIGHT IN
WHATEVER KIND OF CIRCUMSTANCES
THEY MIGHT FACE.